- I love Christmas
music, I love Christmas.
I have a terrible memory.
♫ I don't want a lot for Christmas ♫
- Don't-- (laughs)
- There is just one thing I need and I...
- Don't need something presents.
- Just for you to be my man.
I think that's it.
- Make my wish come true.
- All I want for Christmas.
- Is you, yep, that, I knew that one.
It's in Love, Actually, so
that's why I remember it.
♫ Good king Wenceslas looked out ♫
- On the feast of Stephen.
- Who, I, who's Stephen,
Stephen Christmas?
- They had husks of corn and...
- Merry Christmas to Stephen.
Here's a brand new pair of pants.
♫ Jingle bell, jingle
bell, jingle bell rock ♫
- Jingle bell chime and
jingle bell, oh fuck.
- Jingle bell lime. (laughs)
- Bananas, bananas, that's not it, no.
- Somethin' 'n bump thin'.
- Dancin' with horses now.
- The jingle and the jingle
and the jinglin' dinglin'.
- That's the jingle bell rock.
They did it on Mean Girls, right?
♫ On the twelfth day of Christmas
my true love gave to me ♫
- Twelves twelves a twelvin'.
- Eleven...
- Gumdrops dropping.
- Ten lords a leaping.
- Nine, uh, gooses.
- Eight maids a milking,
seven swans a swimming.
- Six things a laying.
- Five golden rings.
- Four mockingbirds.
- Three, I don't know,
two, two, two, two...
- Oh shit, what, and a partridge,
it's a partridge in a pear tree!
- Nailed it!
♫ You're a mean one, Mr. Grinch ♫
- You even have a suit.
- You're as cuddly as a somethin'.
- As a cactus, as... (sighs)
- Aah, I should know this.
- Gaah.
- You're a tiny spotted leopard
and you do not give a fuck.
- Mr. Grinch.
- You're a two decker, two double-decker
cheese something a salami sandwich,
he says something like that.
- Fluh flah flah flah
flah flah, flah flah.
- Fluh flah flah flah flah
flah, bup up up up bow.
- I can do most of these verses, actually.
- Maybe that's my takeaway, is I feel like
I know all of these at heart,
but my mouth doesn't
remember what my heart does.
- Hey, it doesn't matter if
you don't know the words,
just sing your heart out.
- Happy holidays!
- Merry mother effing Christmas.